[Musique]
la grande soirée électorale se poursuit
en bourgogne franche comté dispositif
exceptionnel pour ce premier tour des
élections régionales et départementales
résultats analyses réactions au plus
près des chez vous mais d'abord un mot
jérémy avec notre sondage notre
estimation ipsos steria exactement et
les résultats ce soir en bourgogne
franche comté contredisent tous qui eux
ont pu annoncer les sondages pendant la
campagne puisque c'est marie-guite dufay
la présidente socialiste sortante qui
basculerait en tête de ce premier tour
ce soir 26 2% des suffrages
suivent dans l'ordre le rassemblement
national avec julian 12 23,8 pour cent
gilles platret des républicains à 20,9
pour cent denis therriault la république
en marche 12 7%
ces quatre listes franchissent le seuil
des 10% qui permet de se maintenir au
second tour
elles sont donc en capacité d'être
présente et candidates la semaine
prochaine suivent
stéphanie modde 9,9 pour cent stéphanie
modde qui pourra éventuellement
fusionner avec l'une des quatre listes
qui a déplacé à l'est et dix pour cent
bastien faudot le temps des cerises une
liste soutenue par la france insoumise
et génération notamment
et puis claire rocher de lutte ouvrière
2 4% mais d'abord pour commencer à
écouter cette réaction celle de julien
oudoul il ya quelques minutes on va le
voir il croit à la victoire au deuxième
tour et il appelle à la mobilisation on
écoute julian de nos électeurs
simplement des électeurs de bourgogne
franche comté qui font confiance à
marine le pen
comme partout en france ont décidé de
déserter les urnes
moi je leur dis que là et je le redis la
désertion démocratique c'est faire le
jeu du gouvernement
l'abstention c'est faire le jeu des
modèles macron emmanuel macron comme aux
élections municipales comptait sur
l'abstention pour délégitimer les
scrutins parce qu'il n'a pas d'ancrage
territorial et on voit que partout en
france la république en marche
donc c'est une déroute une déroute en
rase campagne
donc clairement nos électeurs doivent
retrouver le chemin de la démocratie
ils peuvent le faire la victoire je le
redis est possible le rassemblement est
possible
la question c'est le choix quelles
régions on veut pour demain
voilà justement nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau pendant cette déclaration c'est
de direct des soirées électorales
julie en double merci d'être avec toi un
petit mot peut-être sur les premiers
chiffres dont on vient de dont on vient
de parler et notamment le vôtre c'est
pas mon chiffre qui est important c'est
l'abstention qui est importante c'est ça
qui doit nous préoccuper
je pense qu autour de cette table on est
tous des républicains et démocrates et
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de motif de
satisfaction ce soir je place financière
elles vous touchent particulier le
rassemblement national qui est en recul
par d'ailleurs partout en france est pas
spécifique à la bourgade bien sûr c'est
la deuxième fois
de ma vie politique où je fais une
élection sans électeurs et malgré cela
et je tiens à les en remercier malgré ça
elle nous sommes à un point un point et
demi de la candidate sortante qui était
ultra favoriser évidemment par le
contexte
parce que tous les sortants on le voit
partout en france donc font des scores
incroyables compte tenu de l'abstention
j'observe que marie-guite dufay compte
tenu de son statut de sortante fait un
score qui est relativement mauvais
relativement mauvais mais ce que
j'observe aussi c'est que un grand
nombre d'électeurs évidemment dur
assemblée nationale considère
aujourd'hui à tort et je le redis à tort
que l'abstention est un acte patriotique
que l'abstention finalement est une
gifle envoyée aux systèmes et aux
gouvernements
je leur dis qu'ils ont tort je leur dis
qu'ils ont tort parce qu'une abstention
si une voie pour macron la seule manière
de changer les choses
la seule manière d'améliorer leur
quotidien et d'envoyer un signal c'est
de voter pour l'alternance c'est de
voter pour le changement et donc voter
pour la forme on a su alors julien ans
nous nous ont également rejoint sur ce
plateau pendant le décrochage nationale
denis thuriau la tête de liste la
république en marche
jérôme durain président du groupe
socialiste sortant groupe majoritaire et
candidat en saône et loire
et puis bastien photo la tête de liste
de du temps des cerises liste d'union de
partis de gauche avec notamment la
france insoumise et génération jérôme
durain on vient d'entendre julien odoul
les sortants étaient ultra favoriser est
ce que vous faites ce constat également
ce soir mais écoutez je ne sais pas ce
que quel sondage julien odoul à regarder
avant l'élection on est tous très
surpris ce soir du résultat on
n'attendait pas ça on attendait
rassemblement national c'était inespéré
pauvres c'est inespéré c'est une
élection à deux tours
moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on prenne ce
résultat avec la plus grande gravité
parce que c'est un
au niveau de participation qui est
historiquement bas l'état n'a pas été à
la hauteur dans la distribution des
professions de foi il ya quelque chose
qui est inadmissible du point de vue de
la pédagogie qu'on doit aux citoyens
quantité des lecteurs ont été surpris de
ne pas avoir de matériel électoral et ça
a sans doute joué dans la mobilisation
sur le résultat de marie-guite dufay
j'ai pas évidemment pas la même analyse
que que julien houle
je crois que ce résultat je me demande
où le doit aussi à ses propres excès et
je pense que il ya un certain nombre
d'électeurs peu qu'ils se sont trompés
déplacés qui considère que la démagogie
le populisme les excès en tous genres
c'est parce qu'il faut pour la bourgogne
franche comté et on a ce soir un
résultat qui est d'abord un résultat
pour pour les bourguignons franc comtois
pour un projet de rassemblement pour
lancer pour cent oui mais enfin sur ses
66% mais ça pourrait vous rendre modeste
si on est qu'il en a 8 ans et part ça
j'ai pensé à part ça on est très modeste
il ya un deuxième tour et donc du coup
on veut remercier d'abord les électeurs
qui se sont déplacés pour placer le
bulletin de marie-guite dufay dans
l'urne et dire que rien n'est fait et
j'ai entendu l'appel vibrant de julien
odoul nous aussi on va appeler nos
électeurs à porter un projet de
solidarité et de rassemblement pour
cette bourgogne franche comté éviter les
divisions et puis confirmer ce résultat
du rassemblement national avant de
donner la parole à julien aux deux je me
tourne vers vous denis thuriau l'état
n'a pas été à la hauteur ce sont les
mots de jérôme durain qu'est ce que vous
répondez je trouve jérôme durain très
sévère l'état était à la hauteur je
rappelle que ce sont l'ensemble des
partis qui ont presque exigé que ces
élections se tiennent dans un temps très
court et on l'a connue nous tous comme
candidat et on le connaît encore nous
voilà il ya il semble t'il une société
privée qui n'a pas été à la hauteur il
est en tirera les conséquences
d'ailleurs il est demandé que chacun des
mouvements remonte les difficultés qu'il
a rencontrées c'est dans l'intérêt de
l'état que les gens aillent voter
genre si tu la société privée c'est
celle qui a été choisi suite à un appel
d'offres pour distribuer le matériel
électoral le matériel électoral ce sont
toutes ces enveloppes cours soit chez
soi avec l'ensemble des bulletins de
vote et des professions de foi ce n'est
pas le seul sujet c'est pas le sujet non
mais c'est ce dont parlait
j'ai des conditions de vote est un sujet
du scrutin il gèle allongement on a
proposé nous cinq textes de loi 30
amendements pour avoir l'étalement du
vote sur plusieurs jours pouvoir le vote
par procuration
parce qu'on savait qu'après une séquence
sanitaires aussi difficile on aurait des
difficultés
le gouvernement nous a toujours dit pas
de soucie pas de souci donc il ya la
distribution des profits sur l'une des
femmes et il ya aussi ce sujet
l'organisation je vais vous auriez très
très bien pardonnez moi que si on change
les règles qu'on avance on sait très
bien ce que le gouvernement entendra de
l'opposition et que c'est pour les très
graves
voilà je vais me permettre de dire une
chose parce que ça devient assez
insupportable il ya quand même une chose
dans le pays aujourd'hui il ya une crise
politique majeure
vous n'êtes pas aveugle et comme j'ai
longtemps que mr comme vous comme nous
tous autour du plateau
il n'est pas mais l'année normes et puis
là j'ai réussi il est impliqué avec eux
je suis un républicain qui est toujours
été attaché par deux chutes au à
souveraineté populaire
donc il faut qu'on s'incline mais quand
il ya plus de deux ou deux tiers de
français
deux électeurs vigneault franc comtois
qui ne se rendent pas aux urnes
ça signifie que la crise est d'une
gravité sans précédent
c'est la première chose devant laquelle
nous devons tous unanimement nous
rétrécir ça c'est le premier point ça
sent le haut la main c'est la honte a
reçu la photo
la faute à qui sur les restes je vais y
revenir
le deuxième point monsieur thuriau sur
la responsabilité éminente de l'état et
du gouvernement en la matière vous ne
pourrez pas vous défausser plus
longtemps la question centrale
aujourd'hui c'est que nous vivons en
dans la sixième ou septième puissance
mondiale et que l'état n'est même pas
foutu de distribuer des bulletins de
vote et les professions de foi à
l'ensemble des citoyens de ce pays nous
votre histoire de ont fait appel à une
société privée
sinon niveau l'om en 2004 idéologie de
nous laisser le reste en nature
invité de bourdin logiquement et
politiquement je suis opposé à tout
c'est logique de privatisation auquel
votre famille politique s'est rendu
depuis maintenant des années mais la
question centrale
parce que ça c'est votre tambouille
interne l'état il est responsable de
faire respecter le marché d'adrexo votre
histoire de adrexo il faut ils payeront
finalement ils ont leurs pas ils
rappellent que c'est bien tout ça
n'intéresse personne
ça n'intéresse que la république en
marge et le sujet central aujourd'hui
c'est qu'à l'heure où l'on se parle il
ya des gens qui allument leur poste de
télévision et qui sont en train de
découvrir qu'il ya eu des élections en a
fait les frais mais c'est tout voilà où
l'on annonçait libre a aussi j'en ai
fait les frais donc personne n'ya
intérêt est effectivement moi je partage
je ne dis pas que monsieur d'où il n'y a
pas eu des lecteurs que n'a pas eu assez
c'est ça le vrai drame et on a une
responsabilité et tous ceux qui se
soucient son succès dont une
responsabilité d'intéresser à des
élections qui sont compliqués à faire
comprendre à nos électeurs je pense que
vous l'avez vu et surtout voilà
différencier le département d'une région
c'est pas facile alors lui qui m'a mis
sur votre votre le chiffre 12 5% c'est
une estimation c'est un chiffre
extrêmement dur est ce que vous vous
dites c'est un accident industriel pour
moi non c'est 12,7 je crois même déjà
déçu pour l'instant cette hausse est
moins déçu parce qu'on a tous envie de
faire mieux et je suis sûr que mes
concurrents aussi donc évidemment en
même temps c'est très bien que s'il ya
peu de votants général ça ne bénéficie
pas à la majorité présidentielle
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
odoul bien au contraire
donc voilà après faut tirer positif
d'abord absence de dynamique du
rassemblement national qui est bien plus
bas qu'il ya six ans et qui n'est
sûrement pas le premier annoncé ça j'en
suis satisfait parce que je le combats
après ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que ça permet la majorité présidentielle
d'être qualifiés au deuxième tour en
tout cas dans cette région je savais
bien que vous allez vous maintenir ça
veut dire que j'ai réfléchi que j'ai 115
autres colistiers que je vais réfléchir
avec eux trois options se maintenir
fusionner se retirer l'édition est ce
que vous souhaitez alors est très
clairement est-ce que vous souhaitez
discuter avec la liste de marie-guite
dufay en pour une éventuelle fusion
je suis quelqu'un de dialogue depuis je
me suis lancé en politique vous agir
avec des gens de toutes tendances sauf
le rassemblement national
donc ce n'est pas une nouveauté pour moi
maintenant il ya une possibilité pour
moi d'aller plus loin
donc la réflexion que je partage avec
mes colistiers a parlé la présidente de
région marie-guite dufay a tenu une
ligne très claire depuis le début de
cette campagne cette courte campagne
cette campagne difficile
ces rassemblement de la gauche
on a déjà fait venir thuriau n'est pas à
gauche pour ton doit entendre ou pas
parce que c'est ce que vous entendez
c'est ce que je dis c'est à dire que
nous on pense que faire de mauvaises
addition ça fait un mauvais résultat
d'ailleurs ça même était de tester dans
des sondages que vous fermez la porte ce
soir écoutez nous nous on a une ligne
qui est de parler avec les gens de
gauche on l'a dit dans la campagne on va
pas dire c'est pas tout à fait ce que
nous a dit patrick molinoz sur le
plateau précédent vous n'êtes pas tous
d'accord je suis on est tous d'accord
c'est la ville après la présidente de
région marie-guite dufay a dit qu'elle
voulait rassembler la gauche on a
commencé à le faire il ya le prg de
patrick molis dose il ya le parti
communiste français
nous avons discuté avec europe ecologie
les verts avec d'autres avec le pôle
écologique avec d'autres formations ce
côté un plus large rassemblement dès le
premier tour ça n'a pas été possible
notre ligne c'est la rassemblement de la
gauche donc c'est clair
et après je pense que au vu de
l'instabilité dans laquelle on est
des résultats qui sont quand même très
incertain parce que celui qui donne le
résultat du contour aujourd'hui là il
est fort moi je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer je ne sais pas qui se mobilisera
donc je pense que notre impératif c'est
confirmé ce résultat
je n'ai vittek on est je vous présente
le maintien avantage vous coupe la
parole on va tout de suite partir en
préfecture de dijon marie-guite dufay
est en train de s'exprimer on écoute
pour être plus solidaire
c'est ça à la ligne de fractions 1
alors est-ce qu'on reste on revient sur
marie-guite dufay marie-guite dufay qui
est donc la présidente socialiste
sortante elle parle alors il parle mais
on ne l'entend pas je voulais dit je
suis en recherche d'une alliance avec ma
famille de gauche qu'elles recherchent
une alliance avec la famille de gauche
marie-guite dufay vaste et un photo oui
je voulais ajouter un élément en lien
avec ce qu'on s'est dit juste il y a
cinq minutes
voyez-vous monsieur thuriau vous venez
de donner l'illustration parfaite de ce
qu'est la faillite de notre démocratie
vous nous expliquez vous étiez pour le
dialogue au deuxième tour c'est mignon
la main sur le coeur mais il ya trois
jours ou quatre jours si j'ai bien vu ça
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous désignez marie-guite dufay comme la
responsable de l'affreuse liste socialo
communiste et maintenant vous leur
tendez la main mais les gens qui nous
regardent comment vous pouvez les
regarder encore dans les yeux dire ces
choses je veux dire il ya trois jours
c'est vous qui le disiez personne ne
vous a forcé à le faire donc
tenez votre ligne si vous avez des idées
que vous y tenez
tenez les puisque vous lui posez une
question va faire répandre dany duriaux
m'interdis pas de tenir ma vie mais
c'est pas parce que je dialogue et les
autres que je ne tiens pas ma vie vous
savez mac ces derniers jours que jamais
attachés sur les réseaux sociaux mari et
du fils du feu s'en est pas privé non
plus voilà avec semble-t-il une aversion
une majorité présidentielle pour
laquelle elle a appelé à voter en tout
cas pour le présent république noyer sa
cohérence pour garder les regarder des
deux côtés
moi je suis pas un courant je dis
simplement qu'effectivement on a bien
senti qu'aujourd'hui marie-guite dufay
qui avaient une faible majorité
voilà c'est un peu coincé sur son aile
très à gauche et c'est ce qui la gêne
effectivement pour dialogue avec
d'autres
voilà quarante tous les trois lignes de
mort ce soir je dialogue et quelle en
tant qu'élu depuis six ans je la connais
julien au dos l'ont on parle d' allianz
est ce que le rassemblement national
peut gagner la région sans les électeurs
des républicains ce soir voilà on parle
de tripatouillage de fusions
d'acquisitions est ce que ça intéresse
véritablement nos compatriotes
le choix de dimanche prochain c'est quoi
est ce qu'on continue avec la gauche qui
a fait tant de mal à notre région est ce
qu'on continue avec une bourgogne
franche comté qui dernière en terme
d'attractivité
mais est-ce que vous échangez arrêté
prendre oui la victoire est aussi le il
a dit voir et cosimo alliance avec
gilles platret la victoire est possible
et j'en appelle déjà à tous nos
électeurs qui ne sont pas allés voter à
se rassembler à se rassembler et à se
bouger et je leur dis amicalement voilà
un petit peu vulgairement bougez vous
bougez vous parce que moi j'en ai assez
de vous entendre râler art et arrêtez de
râler sur les réseaux sociaux
arrêtez de dire que ça va mal si vous ne
votez pas si vous voulez que ça change
si vous voulez que votre vie s'améliore
si vous en avez marre des
délocalisations si vous en ai marre du
chômage
si vous avez marre de passer après les
migrants mais bougez vous aux urnes mais
ça c'est le message que j'ai envie de
leur dire et ensuite les électeurs de
gilles platret évidemment évidemment moi
j'en ai entendu qu ils se disent tous
sauf la gauche on ne veut plus de cette
gauche sectaire on ne veut plus de cette
gauche qui a fait beaucoup de mal nos
territoires en termes de fractures en
termes de centralisme dijonnais la
ruralité été méprisés par marie-guite
dufay pendant ce dernier mandat
c'est pour vous qu'on a vu une réunion
aujourd'hui un mois je dis moi je dis
aux électeurs aient l'air de voter en
responsabilité est ce que voulait faire
barrage à la gauche
vous voulez en reprendre pour six années
de plus je le redis il ya un vote utile
il est clair moi je leur demande pas de
prendre leur carte oùra ce moment
nationale je leur demande pas de
d'apprécier mai et cravate et chemise
genre demande surtout de voter utile et
ça c'est possible et l'arrière et on
l'avait déjà constaté aux municipales
l'an passé c'est que les gens qui
d'ordinaire râler comme vous dites
en votant front national ou
rassemblement national aujourd'hui ils
râlent en allant à la pêche
oui mais je leur dis qu'ils ont tort je
leur dis qu'ils ont tort parce qu'ils
ont été dégoûtés pendant des années de
la démocratie pourquoi parce qu'on a un
système qui n'est pas représentatif
on pourrait reparler de la
proportionnelle intégrale notamment aux
élections législatives
on pourrait reparler des référendum
sont violés quelques années après
notamment celui de 2005 on peut parler
d'un mikari maternelle aujourd'hui
normalement ça vous est favori ça
faisait pas défavorables en tout cas on
va être honnête nos concitoyens ne
savais même pas qu'il y avait deux
élections aujourd'hui on l'a vu dans les
bureaux de vote il était tout surpris
ils ne savaient pas comment ça se
passait pour les départementales pour
les régionales mais tout ça parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu d'information il n'y a pas
eu de clients gouvernementaux alors
qu'on nous avait promis jean castex la
main sur le coeur avait dit durera de
l'information aucune information une
distribution on en a parlé qui était
totalement déficiente et indigne indigne
d'un pays civilisé démocratique donc
clairement la responsabilité elle est
bien du côté du gouvernement
mais moi je dis à nos électeurs je dis à
nos électeurs s'ils veulent
véritablement améliorer leur vie en
bourgogne franche comté il faut pas
râler il faut voter c'est tout merci
messieurs je vous propose qu'on s'arrête
on va faire une petite pause on va
prendre la direction du plateau des
départementales avec 4e série on se
retrouve juste après on continue
merci hézard bonsoir à tous en effet
donc le plateau des départementales avec
gabrielle talon qui me donne les
résultats de la bourgogne et moi même
pour le résultat de franche comté
gabriel vous nous emmenez tout de suite
en saône et loire mais catherine les
premiers résultats en saône et loire
avec eux tout d'abord le canton de 0,6
où la sortante
violaine gilet de la gauche 71 est en
ballottage défavorable face au binôme de
la majorité départementale nathalie
d'amis et michel duvernois dans le
canton de pierre de bresse et d'y aller
deuxième tour ce sera un duel entre la
majorité sortante ray un binôme du
rassemblement national avec notamment
donc bertrand roux front fuyant ce qui
est pas ce rassemblement national alors
qu'il était jusque là dans la majorité
départementale annuelle donc qui sera
donc entre droite et rassemblement
national un deuxième duel cette fois
gosses rassemblement national dans le
canton de saint vallier
c'est viviane perrin alain philibert qui
arrive en tête avec 45 points 28% devant
justine l'orphelin et franck pietà à
25,31 dans le canton de chauffailles il
n y aura pas de second tour puisque
arnaud du
c'est cécile martin sont élus avec 90 58
% des suffrages et puis plus qu'on parle
des lions mais également parlé du canton
de paray le monial le canton du
président sortant andré accary andré
accary réélus dès ce soir avec 76 60 13
% des suffrages et je crois d'ailleurs
qu'on va tout de suite que le retrouver
en direct
andreck avec vous êtes avec nous oui
bonsoir
un mot tout d'abord retrouver élections
tout simplement écouter bercy évidemment
je vais tout d'abord m'adresser aux
électeurs de ce canton et les remercier
et toute l'équipe qui a participé aussi
à l'élection et notamment notre très
nombreux bénévoles qui ont participé aux
opérations électorales ce soir puisque
en effet les équipes étaient nombreuses
comme il y avait 10 ans de la qui a viré
lui un très grand merci avec soi ça je
le disais il y avait que 76% des
suffrages mais une participation comme
même limité à 38,17 alors qu'elle était
de quasiment 50 2 % il ya six ans et oui
c'est on peut le regretter en effet on
voit bien c'est un niveau national alors
en plus il est vrai qu on a surtout
parlé des élections régionales
et donc on peut si on pouvait s'attendre
en effet bien sûr à une abstention assez
forte
c'est une déception les français avaient
l'occasion en effet là aussi d'exprimer
et bien finalement de s'exprimer pour
une équipe en tout cas ils l'ont fait
sur ce canton j'en suis tout à fait ravi
j'aurais bien sûr préféré qu'il soit
beaucoup plus nombreux à participer à ce
scrutin est à l'essai du département
vous êtes confiant pour garder une
majorité confortable au département
j'ai l'impression que la majorité va se
renforcer alors évidemment c'est une
vraie satisfaction
attention le deuxième tour c'est
toujours une opération malgré tout qui
n'est pas gagné d'avancé mais en tout
cas là la tendance est bonne et j'en
suis vraiment très heureux et là aussi
je félicite et bien évidemment les élus
qui dernier les couleurs derniers jours
andré accary on parlait du dudit
communes du canton de saint vallier là
où il ya un duel entre la gauche et le
rassemblement national
est-ce que vous avez une consigne de
vote tout pas donner à vos électeurs
pour écouter les choses sont claires
très clair là où la majorité était
évidemment en concurrence avec le
rassemblement national
et là aussi bien sûr on est plus présent
mais pour moi la question ne se pose pas
et je pense que les électeurs vont avoir
la même démarche que moi c'est à dire
évidemment de ne pas donner leurs voix
au rassemblement national merci merci
beaucoup aux grecs avec catherine c'est
à vous merci gabriel moi je vais vous
donner des résultats de du doubs et de
la haute-saône
tout d'abord audincourt parce que là
c'est vraiment significatif le binôme
sortant à savoir david barbier et carole
tueni qu'ils étaient tous les deux
divers gauche sont battus et sont
qualifiés pour le deuxième tour et
arrive en tête le binôme du
rassemblement national
ils seront opposés au deuxième tour à un
autre binôme de gauche composé du ps et
du divers gauche de damien charlet et
christine koren
donc c'est vraiment une première
information importante un binôme sortant
qui est battue dans le département du
doubs à ornans et béatrix loison est en
ballottage très favorable mais le les 25
% des inscrits n'ont pas été atteints
donc deuxième tour deuxième tour
également donc à pontarlier où se
retrouveront donc le divers de lady vers
droite opposée à karine grosjean et
xavier moïse de la liste d'union de la
gauche à mèche et ça c'est intéressant
christine bouquin la présidente et l'air
du conseil départemental du doubs est en
ballottage très favorable puisqu'elle a
réalisé plus de 71% des suffrages mais
elle n'y a pas sur ce canton
suffisamment d'électeurs pour que le
scrutin soit validé donc elle sera en
ballotage face aux binômes
du rassemblement national un mot
maintenant pour la haute saône à jussey
donc ballottage entre le duo et l'air
sortant bonnart et rythm and qui seront
opposés à des sens éthique est virginie
et nager et loïc raclot donc ajuster et
puis toujours en dessous comme je vous
l'avais dit déjà tout à l'heure
donc isabelle géa et michèle richard
arrive en tête à villersexel c'est donc
deux candidats et l'air est maintenant
puisque nous sommes en automne
eh bien nous allons y rester avec un
reportage donc qui a été tourné
aujourd'hui entre donc puisque pour vous
mieux comprendre le duel qui a lieu
entre à la joyeuse des le sénateur a
l'air de haute saône qui a décidé de
défier le président divers gauche du
département à savoir yves krattinger
tout de suite le reportage des années
qu'ils font de la politique qu'ils
s'affrontent mais jamais il ne s'était
retrouvé l'un contre l'autre lors d'un
même scrutin en 2021 c'est donc le duel
yves krattinger 73 en novembre divers
gauche et président du département
depuis 20 ans n'a pas l'intention de
laisser son fauteuil
candidat à sa propre succession toute
l'équipe est mauvais on fait notre
travail tout au long du mandat encore
plus un autre engagement en la période
répondait me
donc je suis serein face à lui brigands
lui aussi la présidence du département
alain joyandet 67 ans sénateur les
républicains candidats sur le canton de
vesoul 1
un canton remportées par la droite en
2015 mais des élus divers droite qui ont
rallié depuis la majorité départementale
de gauche alain joyandet candidat et
l'eire qui veut que la droite reprenne
la main j'ai dû nous une étude total
quel que soit quelques sur les résultats
c'est quand on a fait son devoir qu'on a
bien réfléchi qu'on a fait un projet
qu'on l'a soumis aux gens soit il vient
de voter sur vienne pas soyez vous soyez
vote pour nous soignerons pas pour nous
mais en tout cas l'important c'est
d'avoir vraiment le sentiment d'avoir
fait son devoir pour les deux hommes
l'attend ce soir est anormalement longue
le double dépouillement prend du temps
quant à la faible participation
elle interpelle le président sortant est
ce que ce sont les nouveaux arrivants ce
sont plutôt les jeunes mais ce que je
sais je sais pas puis une abstention
considérable même si la haute saône
enregistre la meilleure participation de
toute la bourgogne franche comté celles
ci restent trop faibles pour connaître
dès ce premier tour le nom de celui qui
va occuper les lieux pendant les six
prochaines années nous allons maintenant
donner la parole à gabriel pour des
résultats en bourgnon bourgogne
concernant ces départementale avoue
gabriel oui catherine laborde ans dans
la nièvre
on va aller à château chinon
résultat attendu puisque dans ce canton
là et bien se présenter dans que la
merde c'est aussi non sans talent marie
malus
elle finit finalement deuxième année que
de 33 8% des voix est en ballotage face
au duel de go c'est un canton sur lequel
l'alliance centre-droit comptait
beaucoup également dans la nièvre
toujours à fourchambault le deuxième
tour opposera donc un binôme socialiste
et un binôme divers-droite diverses
entre le rassemblement national est
éliminée dès le premier tour alors qu'il
avait réalisé près de 40% au second il y
a 6 ans et puis également en côte-d'or
deux autres résultats à brazey-en-plaine
tout d'abord là encore le rassemblement
national et battus alors qu'ils avaient
réussi à force corps il y a 6 ans
situation à peu près similaire à genlis
puisqu'au deuxième tour eh bien ce sera
un duel droite gauche
et là encore le rassemblement national
est battu voilà catherine merci gabriel
nous allons maintenant en direct au
kursaal à besançon où nous attend
jacques richard d'éthique du
rassemblement national
bonsoir monsieur richard des ti donc
madame algérie a priori fort recul du
rassemblement national
on parle même pas des régionales où
julien odoul a été donc elle n'a obtenu
que la seconde place mais même dans les
départements le rassemblement national a
tendance à diminuer voire dans certains
cantons à s'effondrer vous en dites quoi
à écouter hamada même série moi je vous
trouve fort pessimiste j'ai quelques
résultats que je crois pas que vous ayez
encore cité où on se trouve au deuxième
tour et nous créerons laisser la
surprise la véritable surprise et
l'effondrement
c'est le vote démocratique tout
simplement ailleurs il va y avoir un
deuxième tour avec des sursauts et nous
avons un des binômes qui seront au
deuxième tour de manière stratégique
comme vous l'avez dit à audincourt
vous avez vu aussi qu'un apport ou d'un
cours
avec le binôme que nous avons qui était
très bien placé nous sommes en capacité
de faire tomber de faire tomber
audincourt nous avons aussi bavent nous
sommes particulièrement bien placé aussi
au deuxième tour tout n'est pas perdu et
je pense que les grands gagnants les
grands gagnants ccd abstentionnistes
malheureusement oui justement on a
l'impression que vous n'avez pas su pas
pu mobiliser votre camp écoutez madame
ngiri je crois que là aussi on a fait un
travail de terrain vous nous avez suivi
par ailleurs je vois que la mobilisation
la mobilisation on a essayé de là on a
essayé de la faire effectivement avec un
taux d'abstention qui a pénalisé tout le
monde mais qui a joué sur ce taux
d'abstention des élections peu lisible
on est on le tout le monde est d'accord
là dessus que ce soit au niveau des
cantons que ce soit au niveau
départemental comme au niveau des
régionales une propagande qui n'est
arrivé que dans qui n'est pas arrivé
dans la majorité je suis tenté de vous
dire dans la majorité des des boîtes aux
lettres
là aussi des joueurs comme tout le monde
ça c'est valable pour tout le monde donc
c'est pour exactement mais c'est pour ça
madame mesurer que personne n'a personne
n'a su mobiliser
personne n'a su mobiliser effectivement
dont il n'y a pas de défaite du
rassemblement national
nos idées sont là nos électeurs sont là
d'ailleurs je je prends le moment pour
les remercier de s'être déplacés et je
les appelle à une forte mobilisation
pour ce deuxième tour dans les cantons
où nous serons où nous serons présents
et où nous pouvons faire les basculer ce
canton sur la majorité du rassemblement
national jory tr6 monsieur rien et qu'
on va arrêter là aujourd'hui c'est plus
des aides pour les merci monsieur
richard d'éthique
gabriel gabriel est ce que on peut aller
dans l'yonne maintenant puisque il y à
un direct qui nous attend oui juste
avant moi je te donnais à batista voilà
les résultats du canton du président
engendre au clown écoutait tout à
l'heure patrick gendraud donc en
ballottage pour le deuxième tour face à
un dino mme du rassemblement national et
on va maintenant retrouver donc comme
promis quatre ils ont direct andrée
villiers ce que vous nous entendez vous
entend parfaitement alors on a très peu
de résultats je vous le cache pas nous
on a juste sablier est un canton de sens
est ce que vous vous en avez plus est ce
que vous prie nous les donner alors
moyens un ensemble de canton
effectivement qui dont les résultats
viennent d'apparaître
ici sur les tableaux de la préfecture
avec des résultats qui sont pas
définitif puisque on est encore dans une
zone de 80 à 100 % de précisément
d'information donc il faudra attendre
encore un petit peu pour se fixer de
manière définitive sur les forces en
présence à l'issue de ce premier tour
on le sait dans votre département la
droite une position hégémonique vous
pensé réussir à garder une telle
majorité où vous vous préparez déjà en
perdre quelques-uns
vous dites position hégémonique vous
employer un terme qui est réducteur où
finalement si les électeurs veulent
envoyer des élus de droite et du centre
droit c'est qu'il corresponde à
l'enracinement politique de ceux de ce
département donc après qu'est ce qui
peut se passer dans avec un taux
d'abstention effectivement très élevé
qui est en évolution à partir des
résultats de 2015 d'ailleurs puisque sur
2015 on était avec des taux d'abstention
de l'ordre de 50%
on passe à 60 % donc je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui s'interroger sur les raisons
de la désaffection de de ces
consultations de ces élections qu'elles
soient départemental ou régional
et puis un autre sujet moins deux sujets
au fond qui viennent andré billardon
vous en plus marquées par le taux de
l'abstention qu'à part les résultats de
votre majorité à l'abstention c'est
premièrement que la loi notre à créer
les conditions de l'éloignement de
l'électeur de ses représentants la
proximité n'est plus de mise
et puis la distribution des documents
c'est une véritable catastrophe je pense
que quand on veut
gagner de l'argent sur l'envoi des
professions de foi eh bien on continue
de confier à une belle entreprise qui a
fait ses preuves et internationale pour
faire en sorte que la fondation a lancé
je préviens on va devoir vous laisser il
faut qu'on aille huit départements à
faire il faut qu'on fasse le tour je
vais redonner la parole à quatre finir
et catherine oui je vais vite la prod
parce qu'être bon on va on va déborder
la mode est fait nous allons retrouver
yves krattinger donc en direct de vesoul
c'est le président divers gauche sortant
de haute saône
tout d'abord donc j'ai un résultat de la
haute saône c'est le sait le vôtre yves
krattinger à savoir que vous-même et
edwige m
vous êtes réélu avec 67% des suffrages
donc visiblement être sortant que ce
soit pour les régionales où que ce soit
pour les départementales c'est quand
même un plus par rapport à ses
concurrents oui forcément enfin on me
dit que je suis réélu je ne sais pas
parce que je n'ai pas vérifié les règles
avec précision donc j'ai quand même
l'hiver non non non non parce que là ce
sont les résultats officiels qui
viennent de la préfecture et il y a une
participation de 44% dans votre
département et vous même avec 67%
vous avez fait le quart des inscrits
donc a priori nous quant à l'avs à
france 3 la télé quand on donne des
résultats
ils sont vérifiées par les préfectures
de je suis encore d'accord j'accepte
j'accepte cette augure donc
l'attribution de la prime aux sortants
ça marche
ouais enfin la prime à ceux qui
fournissent un travail toute l'année sur
le terrain tout au long de leur mandat
il n'y a pas que la prime au sortant
s'il m'avait jamais rencontré n'est ni
ma colistière edwige m il n'aurait pas
et voter comme ça donc ici on est
maintenant ici documents sortants il ya
surtout le travail sur le département le
oui le front le front national leur
palau
le rassemblement national est beaucoup
plus bas que ce qui était annoncé à moi
même j'avais mis un bémol que ce que
j'entendais et il y aura peu de
candidats du rassemblement national au
deuxième tour et on va être dans des
dandys comment dire des des compétitions
plus traditionnelles entre des candidats
de qui sont candidats sous la bannière
de la majorité qu'elle et d'autres qui
conteste cette majorité
j'ai juste une petite parenthèse sur
vesoul 1 est ce que alain joyandet a
réussi son pari ou pas vous avez déjà
une tendance rapidement à moi je passais
par mois qu'ils prononcent les résultats
de vesoul
je sais qu'il n'est pas je sais qu'il
n'est pas en tête d'après ce qu'on m'a
dit mais bon c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'aléas donc j'attendais la
tendre et lire le journal attentivement
d'un matin j'écouterai la télé pour le
résultat exact comme officiel pour mon
élection officielle
les résultats merci beaucoup yves
krattinger nous allons tout de suite à
belfort retrouver samia jaber samia
jaber donc quelle est votre réaction
face aux résultats que nous avons sur le
territoire de belfort
j'annonce tout de suite ce sont des
résultats extrêmement partiel bonsoir
et bien pour le moment les résultats que
nous avons donc la gauche était sortante
sur trois cantons nous sommes en tête
sur trois cantons dont je voudrais déjà
remercié l'ensemble des électeurs qui
ont fait le l'effort de venir voter avec
un taux d'abstention qui est évidemment
catastrophique pour nous et qui doit
évidemment nous interroger nous sommes
en tête sur trois cantons nous
considérons que nous avons une grosse
marge de possibilités pour le 2ème tour
parce que malheureusement dans les
abstentionnistes il ya beaucoup
d'électeurs de gauche qui jusque-là
voyait voilà un raz-de-marée l air sur
belfort et ce soir l'information c'est
que la gauche résiste plutôt bien et
donc nous souhaitons vraiment pouvoir
faire basculer le département
dimanche prochain c'est encore possible
deux cantons
sont encore gagnable les trois que nous
avons donc nous permettrait d'obtenir
les cinq cantons la majorité
merci donc on madame jamais achevée
terminé en donnant des résultats du pays
de montbéliard qui a été très attendue
parce que dans ces trois cantons à
savoir bavent bethoncourt et valentigney
il y à des primaires à gauche et c'était
intéressant de voir un tout d'abord dont
concernant bavent bruno baudrey
marie-paule brand qui sont des binômes
lr divers droite sont en ballotage face
à roland boyaux et géraldine grangier
donc du rassemblement national
donc de toutes façons ce canton qu'ils
étaient tenus par la gauche bascule à
droite ou au rassemblement national la
semaine prochaine à bethoncourt pareil
c'est le rassemblement national qui
arrive en tête là et c'est avec 29% des
voix suivi par magali duvernois et
albert matocq rabot qui réalisent plus
de 26% des suffrages et il y aura donc
au deuxième tour un duel entre
rassemblement national et divers vosges
et je termine par valentigney ou
frédéric barbier le député et l'air em
du pays de montbéliard et martin voit
des divers gauche sont en ballottage et
là aussi nous aurons droit à un duel
avec le binôme du rassemblement national
il me reste quelques secondes pour vous
dire que nous n'avons pas encore tous
les résultats mais que dans le prochain
épisode des départementales vous aurez
tous promis juré à tout à l'heure et
âmes
merci beaucoup catherine retour ici sur
le plateau des régionales on va
commencer par écouter une réaction celle
de la présidente sortante socialiste
marie-guite dufay qui vous allez le voir
appel à rassembler la gauche et rien
qu'à gauche on écoute je me trouve en
tête est effectivement une bonne
surprise
maintenant je pense que le combat est
loin loin d'être terminée parce que
justement le poids de cette abstention
il engendre des incertitudes très forte
très forte et pour le second tour et
bien il faut que tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs que je
défends et que je voudrais défendre avec
toute la gauche avec la gauche réunie à
rassembler
eh bien il faut qu effectivement ils se
mobilisent davantage l'enseignement n'a
pas la mercuriale comment pensez-vous un
appel aux candidats à l'ère romaine ce
soir je lance un appel à toute la gauche
c'est un ancien socialiste il est un peu
de gauche encore non pas du tout je
parle de ma famille
ça veut dire que ce soir vous estimez
avec la l'union de la gauche si vous y
arrivez vous pouvez remporter cette
élection sans la république en abris
absolument
voilà marie-guite dufay sans nuances
elles vous claque gentiment denis
thuriau la porte au nez
je n'avais pas encore toqué donc pour
moi j'ai rien que nous existons par nous
mêmes encore une fois ça peut être une
ambition patron bout c'est à dire qu'il
faut écarter l'hypothèse fusion du coup
il vous reste deux solutions soit
maintenir votre candidature être
candidat dimanche prochain soit vous
retirer qu'est ce que vous allez choisir
j'ai pas du tout envisageable que je me
retirais l'heure où je vous parle ce que
je vais choisir c'est tout à l'heure
avec mes 115 colistiers réponse dans
quelques heures on dirait c'est prendre
un risque notamment une victoire du
rassemblement national
balade un disque aujourd'hui
expliquez-nous votre analyse
mathématiquement ça me semble compliqué
aujourd'hui pour rassemblant d'anciens
maintenant voilà il est clair qu'on l'a
toujours dit nous ne sommes pas là pour
faire passer l'extrême droite
les joueurs biarrots 12 mathématiquement
c'est fernand vous fait la même analyse
que votre voisin alors déjà je sais pas
pourquoi on part de risque c'est quoi le
risque de l'alternance vous savez je
veux bien qu'on essaye à chaque fois de
caricaturer mais l'alternance c'est
naturel de notre pays
l'alternance et quand on est déçus d'une
politique on en change et l'alternance
est sain pour la démocratie
ce serait simple ans la bourgogne
franche comté la bourgogne franche comté
ça fait 17 ans que les socialistes
est-ce que la bourgogne franche comté se
porte mieux et pour guinot et les franc
comtois se porte mieux non non quand on
a un bilan aussi affligeant mais de 145
mille chômeurs 400000 pauvres des
délocalisations en cascade des plans
sociaux qui se multiplient des
régionales ou plus avec l'initiative
monsieur du rhin c'est votre bilan j'en
suis naïma jade raconte alain mais c'est
votre bilan donc moi je dis que
marie-guite dufay a raison dans un sens
cette élection n'est pas joué cette
élection ce sont les électeurs qui vont
se mobiliser dimanche prochain qui vont
décider ce sont eux qui peuvent faire
gagner de l'alternance et moi j'appelle
aura
langlement rassemblement déjà des
électeurs qui ne sont pas allés voter et
dont la plupart partagent nos idées et
rassemblement des électeurs aient l'air
si je veux vous faire gagner leurs idées
aussi gérant n'avait réalisé que jérôme
durain quand denis thuriau a dit je
n'envisage pas de retirer ma candidature
au deuxième tour vous avez dit vous
prenez un risque quand il a dit vous
êtes joueur vous êtes loire c'est vrai
je ne suis pas joueur
moi je ne suis pas joueur est à vous
c'est facile vous êtes en tête n'annonce
rien n'est facile
on a parlé de l'abstention n'a parlé de
l'instabilité on sait tous que c'est
très difficile on ne sait pas qui se
mobilisera le le week-end prochain
donc il ya un appel à la mobilisation de
ceux qui veulent poursuivre un travail
de rassemblement dans l'intérêt des
bourguignons franc comtois mais vous
êtes voilà ça veut dire que vous lui
demander de se retirer mais moi je pense
je pense qu'il doit être intelligent
comme il l'a dit dans la presse ça veut
dire quoi être intelligent je sais pas
il faut lui demander
visiblement c'est plus les mêmes
versions qui a quelques jours d'être
intelligent ça veut dire se donner
toutes les chances pour qu'on ait un
projet qui soit dans l'intérêt des
habitants de cette région et que ce ne
soit pas monsieur odoul et l'extrême
droite qui arrive à la tête de cette
région parce que je crois qu'il ya un
petit problème d' analyse de julien
odoul sur la situation
il a une rampe vient au dulce le rn il
partait à 30%
le problème c'est que ses propres
actions ses propres excès l'ont pénalisé
mais on voit bien que de rennes baisse
dans toutes les régions mais très bien
le rhin très bien enfin les migrants
écoutez quand vous agressé une femme
voilée dans l'hémicycle quand vous dites
de vous faites des plaisanterie de très
mauvais goût sur le suicide des paysans
quand vous ne cessèrent se dénoncer
quand vous ne cessez dénoncé pas de
voter contre vérités les migrants tout
ça n'intéresse pas les gens les gens ils
veulent 6 le boulot et veulent des
mobilités ils veulent de la solidarité
nous on veut rassembler vous voulez
divisée ça n'a pas pris ça ne prendra
pas et à la fin l'élection la fin du
week-end prochain il y aura une question
est est-ce jouer marie-guite dufay ou
julien odoul peuvent être président de
région et moi je crois que vu ce qui
s'est passé dans cette dernière semaine
ils ont la conviction marie-guite dufay
elle peut continuer à peu dans le camp
de monsieur durand et eux seuls denis
thuriau effectivement vous avez eu cette
formule que tout le monde n'a pas
compris de la même manière je serai
intelligents au soir du premier tour
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là c'est
je suis juriste donc un texte de loi
sas interprète et j'ai le sentiment que
d'ex prononce une phrase elle est
interprétée être intelligent ça veut
dire vous irez vous allez au rebut c'est
vous dire ce que ça voulait dire que
dans ma tête après chacun fait ce qu'il
veut
ça veut dire que j'ai toujours dit c'est
depuis le début de la campagne
je ne permettrai pas au rassemblement
national extrême droite de gagner ça
c'est clair et vous considérez ce soir
que le maintien de cette candidature ne
favorise pas le rassemblement national
moi ça serait dramatique pour notre
région bourgogne franche comté
le rassemblement national l'extrême
droite n'est pas un mouvement comme à
d'autres il ne repose pas sur notre
nouvelle offre commune après on peut
s'entendre ou pas voilà ça c'est clair
et je pense que nous le partageons donc
pour moi ça serait et en tant que
citoyen suicidaire pour notre région
donc je le dis moi j'invite les gens à
se mobiliser mais à réagir par rapport
un risque à son au national qui est sans
doute moindre aujourd'hui même alors
griffe
il faut s'en méfier toujours et moi
j'invite effectivement nos électeurs à
prendre le chemin des élections le 27
et c'est de leur responsabilité que nous
le faire rapidement bastien photo quelle
latitude aura votre liste par rapport au
deuxième tour on sent le sort un quand
tout sera dépouillé mais pour l'heure il
semble peu probable que nous franchi sur
les 5 % donc donc en tout état de cause
on a appelé au rassemblement de la
gauche et on voudra faire gagner la
gauche les écologistes au second tour
allez je redonne les estimations sorties
des yeux en avant de rendre l'antenne à
au national marie-guite dufay basculera
en tête ce soir sont assortis d une ipp
sauce star hier notre partenaire avec 26
6% ça a bougé un tout petit peu suivent
dans l'ordre julien odoul gilles platret
et denis thuriau ses quatre listes
peuvent se maintenir pour le second tour
et puis suivent à nouveau stéphanie
modde bastien photo est claire rocher
dans cet ordre vous découvrez les
estimations sortie des urnes donc voilà
on va prendre un petit peu de hauteur
tout de suite avec les chiffres
en france nous on va se donner
rendez-vous dans moins d'un quart
d'heure avec sur notre plateau
marie-guite dufay stéphanie modde alain
joyandet françois patriat entre autres
merci à tout à l'heure
m
[Musique]